I am living for this mini Josie and the
cat
he kept partially getting some of the
band back together back together how
does it feel I love my Tara I love
antagonist Alexandra from Josie and I
love that Missy came out to play this
part for us she flew old I shouldn't
reveal this but we shot her part all the
way in Vietnam she said that yeah I was
like thank God you got to go join it on
the fun yes completely and she good Lord
why do I put such an incredible scene
stealer in in the movie why do I do this
to myself she says the same thing about
you she's such a gift I I can't I could
not be a bigger fan of that woman I love
those like it brings back the Nostalgia
seeing you three together well I know I
just think maybe
this for a second I mean what do we have
to do to have a Revival of Josie and the
Pussycats I'm the last person who would
know but I do love that made that
soundtrack I think if we just put on the
soundtrack we can just let us let it
take us back to that place and maybe
that can be enough really because
Missy's down Tara's down it's such a
cold classic people will come to me all
the time and I'm like is my favorite
movie ever Sarah I think we're just the
people need to cry for it oh we both
would be down for it we could do that
absolutely I'm also down and you're down
so we got three we gotta make it happen
do Germans make it happen Dijon means
make it happen folks now you brought
your sweet kiddos here tonight to
support my God okay talk about Show
Stoppers your son in a velvet number I
mean he looked sharp okay he picked out
that jacket I did have to talk him out
of some magician style gloves that he
had in a science kit you know what no
that was actually his call he backed out
of those at the last minute but it would
have been a look for sure what did the
kids make of the bright lights of
Hollywood and Mama's films I mean I
think this is gonna be the first movie
of mine that I've actually said kids I
need you to sit through this and if you
don't like it you gotta zip it and you
got to just stay there you better just
take it on the chin and yeah I gotta
watch mom's mom's silly pointy little
face for an hour and a half and then we
can go home listen who could not love it
it was so good it was like it was 10 out
of 10 superb a plus y'all killed it
between Vietnam between the casting I
mean it had everything but you I mean
you are the rom-com queen what is it
about these rom-coms that keeps you
coming back
it's cause I mean it like I love him
with my whole heart I'm a fool for love
I don't know what else to say we are we
all
uh what was it too about this film I
mean shooting in Vietnam to be the only
film to shoot entirely in that country I
mean how special was that
know how they just decided to trust us
and you know to let us just run around
their insanely beautiful country I mean
I cannot say enough about the Vietnamese
crew uh we had department heads from
Singapore from Canada we were a truly
International Group but the Vietnamese
crew is the backbone of this film and I
do not know how our brilliant director
Stephen sushita pulled this off I am not
going to pretend that this movie was
easy it looks like we got paid to go on
vacation but it was not easy and uh yeah
he's he's a miracle worker I feel like a
lot of people are going to put Vietnam
on their bucket list Missy said she
brought the whole fam did you bring the
fam to Vietnam I did bring the fail
come on you guys it's quick flight just
mom's mom's gig's pretty cool oh my
goodness mom's gig is pretty cool my mom
came along it was a family affair and we
were truly embraced by the people there
I can't say enough good things and it's
a family affair tonight between your
your family and then also your Josie and
the Pussycats family I mean however are
you with emotion this is a lot don't
make me cry
I'm just kidding I'm okay okay we love a
good cheer on YouTube oh trust me if I
have to go upstairs and say a few words
I'm going to give you a full Water Works
I cannot even anybody got some tissue
around here
like you're joking but like you're not
and I it's gonna be bad I'm I could not
I don't know how Netflix has now trusted
me for the second time with such an
incredible opportunity it's there's a
reason there's a reason don't sell
yourself short like I said you are the
rom-com queen what is what is next for
you I know you just signed a big deal a
producing gig like I mean what you have
done your homework I'm very we love you
Eddie too
look what's up your sleeves
uh I'm very excited about this
partnership that I've signed with Mar
Vista Entertainment we have a lot on the
go I'm about to start a Christmas movie
that should be ready for this year
there's no reason we can't do it Merry
Christmas to us thank you thank you very
much it's called rescuing Christmas it's
about someone who makes the dire mistake
of wishing away Christmas and then has
to somehow bring it back I started doing
that and then I'm doing a very
self-referential rom-com called there
she goes that's about a kind of like a
cynical actress who made a lot of
rom-coms who has to plan her parents
anniversary with her ex-boyfriend from
high school
and then and then a Josie and the
Pussycats Revival
obviously
in this at some point on your plate
thank you so much for your time
[Music]